[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing events that transpired in the
harry potter universe after the books
and films ended with the latest
fantastic beast film on the way the
secrets of dumbledore we can expect to
learn even more information about the
wizarding world before harry ron and
hermione embarked on their journey at
hogwarts however what i want to hone in
on today are the events that happened
afterwards what happened to hagrid draco
harry let's dive in
10. voldemort i know what you're
thinking didn't voldemort die
well technically yes his physical form
was destroyed
but that certainly doesn't mean that
voldemort met his true end you see
because of the cursed life that
voldemort chose he was sent to a place
that is neither representative of life
nor death voldemort had sacrificed his
soul on countless occasions doing
anything and everything he could to
achieve his goal of immortality
during his lifetime voldemort committed
atrocity after atrocity murdering people
to create horcruxes and even killing and
drinking the blood of a unicorn an act
so vile that the drinker is destined to
have a cursed existence
so you see voldemort's soul could never
have been at rest and for the life that
he chose to live he had to pay the
ultimate price an existence in limbo
limbo is often perceived as a forgotten
or ignored place a place that
interestingly enough would have been a
stark reminder of voldemort's formative
years and he was left at wool's
orphanage as a baby 9. neville
longbottom after the battle of hogwarts
neville didn't waste any time in
pursuing a career as an aura and gifted
aura he was however it later became
clear that being an aura wasn't his true
passion and when he was offered a
position at hogwarts by now headmistress
minerva mcgonagall he accepted you see
neville was also particularly passionate
about one subject while at school
and it just so happened that his new
role would have him working under her
biology department head pomona sprout
neville would eventually go on to marry
former classmate hannah abbott a
hufflepuff student and former member of
dumbledore's army because hannah worked
as a landlady for the leaky cauldron it
was only natural that neville and hannah
would live upstairs where they lived for
many years after some time hannah
eventually applied for the job of matron
at hogwarts 8. ron weasley the epilogue
certainly gave away aspects of ron's
future particularly as he is shown
sending his children off to hogwarts a
platform nine and three quarters
alongside his new wife hermione granger
the pair had two children rose and hugo
granger weasley in the epilogue ron and
hermione can be seen sending rose after
hogwarts along with harry's son albus
in addition to marrying hermione ron
pursued the career path of vanora and
eventually became an aura for the
ministry of magic
jk rowling had this to say of ron
joining the ministry
harry and ron utterly revolutionized the
aura department rowling said they are
now the experts it doesn't matter how
old they are or what else they've done
rowling also emphasized that by joining
the ministry harry and ron helped
revolutionize it into a really good
place to be
they made a new world rowling said
however ron didn't remain at the
ministry forever and later left so that
he could help out his brother george
weasley with the weasley's wizarding
weezers joke shop it has also been
expressed that despite ron's terrible
driving track record he did eventually
obtain a muggle driving license
even if he had to place a confunder's
charm on the driving instructor to get
it 7. hermione granger the first thing
hermione did after the battle of
hogwarts was find her parents if you
don't remember hermione had to make a
difficult choice during the war with
voldemort in which she wiped their
memories and convinced them to relocate
to australia this was all in the effort
of protecting them but it was a somber
moment for sure
fortunately with voldemort out of the
way this gave her an opportunity to
track them down and restored memories
that she had previously wiped
after this in typical hermione fashion
she ended up going back to hogwarts in
order to attain her mutes
after this she began her post-hogwarts
career at the department for the
regulation and control of magical
creatures
where she was able to help improve the
lives of house elves and the like after
some time in the position she eventually
moved to the department of magical law
enforcement as she was instrumental in
helping to abolish pro-pure blood laws
oh yeah and during all of this hermione
and ron weasley became a proper item
going on to get married and have two
children
and as if hermione hadn't done enough in
her post-hogwarts years it's been
expressed that in 2019 she even became
minister for magic hermione's life
post-stealthy hallows certainly wasn't
short of excitement
6. harry potter in the epilogue for the
final installment we learned that harry
ended up marrying shocker ginny weasley
and that they had two sons james sirius
and albus severus as well as a daughter
lily luna unlike hermione harry never
returned to hogwarts to finish his nudes
but he did dive right into his career as
an aura at the ministry of magic
as it turns out harry was able to
achieve the honor of head aura at the
ripe age of 26.
it's also been revealed that in addition
to raising his own kids harry spent a
considerable amount of time with teddy
lupin the orphan son of remus and tonks
teddy was officially raised by his
grandmother but harry helped whenever he
could
harry ron and hermione were also
eventually immortalized on chocolate
frog cards for their contributions to
wizarding society
5. george weasley what happened to
george can best be summarized by rolling
herself
a lot of readers asked me was george all
right and of course he wouldn't be all
right would he that's the reality but i
think that he married angelina who was
actually fred's ex maybe it's a bit
unhealthy but i think that they would
have been happy as happy as he could be
without fred i think he really would
have felt like part of himself died i
don't think that george would ever get
over losing fred which makes me feel so
sad
however he names his first child and son
fred and he goes on to have a very
successful career helped by good old ron
ron joined george at weasley's wizarding
weezers which became an enormous money
spinner 4. luna lovegood it turns out
that later in life luna went on to
become a rather famous major zoologist
for those unfamiliar with the profession
madge's zoologist is a wizard or witch
who studies magical creatures
this profession shouldn't come as a
surprise
given that luna exhibited an affinity
for magical creatures during the harry
potter story properly introducing harry
to thestrals in the order of the phoenix
the perhaps most notable matches
zoologist is newt's commander who wrote
fantastic beasts and where to find them
interestingly enough luna actually went
on to marry rolf scamander newt's
grandson it has been expressed that for
their wedding luna dressed in typical
eccentric lunar fashion sporting a
rainbow dress and tiara with unicorn
horns
later on sometime between the years 2008
and 2014 the pair had two sons lorkhan
and lykander as an adult luna remained
close friends with harry ron and
hermione in fact luna made such an
impression on harry that he named his
daughter lily luna after his mother and
of course luna a true honor according to
rowling luna never changed she remained
a quirky lovable self which is what i
think we all hoped for
3. hagrid it turns out that hagrid
simply continued working at hogwarts in
his usual posting the only thing that
hagrid loved more than hogwarts was his
love of magical creatures which explains
why he would choose to continue on as
professor for the care of magical
creatures at the school
hagrid is also referenced in the
epilogue by harry while speaking to his
son albus
bye al said harry that's his son hugged
him don't forget hagrid's invited you to
tea next friday don't mess with peeves
don't jewel anyone till you've learned
how and don't let james wind you up the
epilogue of harry potter gave us a
glimpse of 19 years into the future
which would make the year 2017 and
hagrid 89 years old
however thanks to the longevity of
wizard kind i'm sure that hagrid was
still very sprightly
in addition to teaching at hogwarts it's
been suggested that hagrid may have at
one point further pursued a relationship
with madame maxime however the two
eventually proved to be too different to
make things work
2. draco malfoy
as it turns out draco's post hogwarts
life and well overall demeanor has been
written about extensively on pottermore
it's also a bit somber the biggest
revelation was that he became less of a
pureblood fanatic the events of draco's
late teens forever changed his life he
had had the beliefs with which he had
grown up challenged in the most
frightening way he had experienced
terror and despair
seen his parents suffer for their
allegiance and had witnessed the
crumbling of all that his family had
believed in
after the events of the second wizarding
war lucius found his son as affectionate
as ever but refusing to follow the same
old pure bloodline draco married the
younger sister the fellow southern
astoria greengrass who had gone to a
similar though less violent and
frightening conversion from pureblood
ideals to a more tolerant life view was
felt by narcissa and lucius to be
something of a disappointment as a
daughter-in-law as astoria refused to
raise their grandson scorpius in the
belief that muggles were scum
family gatherings were often fraught
with tension
also he seemingly mellowed out a bit
leading a life of leisure instead of
working to overturn the forces of light
or establish dominion over muggles like
lucius did
i imagine that draco grew up to lead a
modified version of his father's
existence independently wealthy without
any need to work draco inhabits malfoy
manor with his wife and son as mentioned
above the bear had a child
scorpius malfoy who attended hogwarts at
the same time as albus severus potter in
a tragic turn of events astoria actually
ended up dying quite young
falling victim to a blood-borne family
curse this left draco a single father
who lived out his days mostly alone
1. the dursleys interestingly enough
very little is revealed about the
dursleys after they pack up and head off
however it turns out that dudley's
moment of redemption the deleted scene
where he shakes harry's hand may have
had quite an impact on their
relationship
in fact it is later revealed by rowling
that despite dudley's years of abuse
towards harry they were later on
christmas card terms
as he grew older dudley developed into a
decent man very much unlike the
tyrannous force of nature that he
embodied in his youth dudley even
eventually got married and had a family
of his own raising two muggle children
harry and dudley would still see each
other enough to be on christmas card
terms but they would visit more out of a
sense of juicy and sit in silence so
that their children could see their
cousins
this suggests that they were never quite
friends but certainly cordial to one
another perhaps stemming from the mutual
respect they gained for one another
later in life
as for vernon and petunia it seems as
though harry may not have seen them
again as their relationship was never
particularly good though petunia
certainly harbored affection for harry
deep within she never made the same
attempt that dudley made to reconcile
with him which was likely the reason for
them never reconnecting it's also been
suggested that after the fall of
voldemort the dursies were simply
escorted back to their home in little
wenjing where they remained for the rest
of their lives
and that's it for this video do you want
another one of these with even more
characters comment down below also don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you